everybody and welcome to support
i don't know about you all but uh this
is an exciting day
for me finally uh after a
long year there is finally a very
bright light at the end of this long
coming
so thank you all so much for joining us
today i
i have had the opportunity to tour sport
rock with lilith
this business started back in 1994
and it's run to what we see here today
another site also here in
northern virginia 40 000 square feet of
just elevated rock climbing
opportunities here as a matter of fact
as president
uh asked mr president
i would like to display some of our
campuses
[Music]
because of simon
[Music]
i want you to all join me and give a
round of applause to the president and
first lady of the united states of
[Music]
america
i want to also acknowledge that dr biden
who is one of my fellow state
employees we are so grateful that you
are
teach here in virginia at northern
virginia community college so please
welcome
[Applause]
as you probably know there are a number
of dignitaries here
with us today and i i'd like to give it
my best attempt at recognizing
some of them we have congressman jerry
connelly jerry thank you for being with
us today
[Applause]
my favorite lieutenant governor
congressman don
beyer welcome
[Applause]
senator george barker i saw in order
senator good to see you this morning
senator adam evan thank you very much
for your leadership
we have the speaker the first woman
speaker of the house of delegates
speaker eileen philippo welcome
and our leader in the uh delegate house
of delegates charnel here and charnel
welcome
[Applause]
our mayor justin wilson is here with us
today justin
we have numerous members of our local
council and school board thank you all
so much for being here and your
leadership over this past year and
finally
superintendent uh greg hutchins for
helping to put all this together thank
you
it is also great to see all the students
with us today and teachers
[Applause]
they have joined us from schools right
here in alexandria and i want to tell
everybody that this past
14 months have no doubt been a very
difficult
and unprecedented time for our students
our teachers
and school staff they have literally
made
sacrifices and they are our heroes
and on behalf of all of us please thank
our teachers our staff and our students
today we mark a tremendous milestone
in our fight against covet 19.
as of 1201 this morning
for the first time since march
2020 there are no limits
or capacity or distancing in virginia's
restaurants
businesses offices or other venues
that's something
that we can all be proud of
we are closer to a more normal
life than we have been in the past 14
months and
i don't know about for you but for me
that feels
really good for this we can thank the
vaccines
and the scientists and researchers who
developed them
we are now roughly six months into the
vaccine rollout
and i'm proud to say that 66
of virginia adults have had their first
shot
54 more than half
of virginians are fully vaccinated which
puts us
14th amongst all states and ahead of
other states in the south
those are tremendous numbers and i'm
fully confident that virginia
will hit president biden's goal of 70
of adults getting their first shot by
july the 4th
we can see yeah
we can see in real time that the more
people get vaccinated
the fewer people get covert it is
very simple math our case counts have
been dropping
for weeks six weeks ago we had an
average
of over 1600 new cases per day
today we have an average of fewer than
400
new cases a day numbers we haven't seen
since
april of 2020 our daily new infection
rate
is the ninth lowest in the nation
and third lowest east of the mississippi
our hospitalizations and deaths are
dropping
as well this is a direct result of
people
getting vaccinated i am grateful to
every virginian including those 12 and
older
who have done the right thing and gotten
the shot
we are focused on making sure that
getting a vaccine as
is as easy as possible for every
virginia and where communities are
harder hit
by the virus or have more barriers to
excess
we make extra effort we want
everyone to be able to get the shot
we are also just so grateful
to president biden and his
administration
we're able to kick off summer enjoying
the things
that we have always cherished thanks to
your leadership sir and focus on
increasing production of vaccines
getting to the states and finally
getting shots
in arms as governor i can tell you that
having a partner
in the white house makes a huge huge
difference
setting clear goals as he has done and
supporting
us with the resources we need to meet
those goals
and as a doctor i know it also makes a
big difference
when leadership respects science and
follows
its lead
[Applause]
finally this weekend as you all know
is memorial day lifting the capacity
and distancing restrictions will make a
big difference
for those businesses relying on holiday
travels
but we cannot forget the purpose
of memorial day to honor those
military service members who have made
the ultimate sacrifice
for freedom this weekend please
please take the time to remember them
and their sacrifice and to comfort
their families all of our service
members
deserve that thank you all so much
it is my honor to introduce president
biden
welcome to virginia mr president and our
first lady
dr joe biden dr biden
you are no stranger to the city of
alexandria you have taught here at the
community college for many years
we are proud to have both of you here
today
my name is jacob bosley and i'm a high
school junior
i want to start by saying thank you to
president biden
and governor northam because of the
incredible work
that has been done by your
administrations doctors
nurses and volunteers all over the
country
i'm able to be here today fully
vaccinated and without a mask
it feels great and i'm really excited to
get back to normal
and enjoy my summer vacation
when this pandemic started we all made
sacrifices
especially students and young people
in our teachers and school
administrators who are owed
a debt of gratitude for all they have
done for us
students this past year
it's been a long year for months
my brothers and i my parents
we have masked up and kept our social
distance
to protect those who we love and we are
going to keep using
good common sense wear a mask in a large
crowded area
keep our distance and wash our hands for
20 seconds
just as dr fauci said and most
importantly
get vaccinated i've had my second shot
and it's a game changer
my school is back open offering in
person learning
i'm playing sports and hanging out with
my family and friends
with memorial day weekend here i'm
excited to go to the pool
and go on vacation with my friends and
family
last but not least i'm ox decided to
have a normal
senior year of high school this wouldn't
have happened
without americans doing the right thing
and getting vaccinated
and it definitely wouldn't have happened
without the strong leadership behind our
president
mr biden
[Applause]
president biden it is an honor to
welcome you here to the commonwealth of
virginia
and to say thank you thank you
[Applause]
i don't know about you all but uh
following a governor introducing the
president
in front about half the legislature in
the national press
when i was a junior in high school no it
wouldn't be close
i just want you to remember me when
you're president when i go by don't say
joe who okay
before i begin i'd like to say a quick
word about a
an old friend of mine a quick word about
senator john warner i had the privilege
of serving with john for three decades
in the united states senate and i can
say
without hesitation he was a man of
conscience
and a man of honor and in his life
full of honors the most enduring was his
service the people of virginia
and we're going to miss him dearly and
you know john took chances i
was stunned pleased and stunned when
in the middle of my primary john
endorsed me for president united states
it was how things sort of used to be
back in the old days in the united
states and when i first got there
people that wouldn't didn't happen that
often but people would cross the aisle
to work with one another john was a man
of great integrity
and uh and he's missed could be missed
and
virginia was just fortunate to have as
long as they did
now jacob i want to thank you for
sharing your story
and uh i want to uh you pointed out that
uh my wife works for the governor
i wonder if she doesn't pay attention to
me when i'm in london
but all can you decide i'm very proud of
the fact that
jill has teaching is not what
jill does teaching is who she is
and she's done it her her whole adult
life
and she's still doing it i know some
people said when
you're first lady are you going to
continue to teach
she said yes but i don't think she
bargained for having to
teach online initially you know i
i students i watched her
she spent more time four hours a day
for about a month learning how to teach
online
so don't feel bad about y'all
i watch the teachers have to do it
and uh i just want to say that uh you
know
we're in a position now governor northam
i want to thank you for your welcome to
the commonwealth
and i want to thank you for all you're
doing to help win the fight against
kovic
you're one of the best governors in the
country taking this on
you did it from the beginning
[Applause]
and uh mayor wilson
thanks for the passport into the city i
promise i'll leave in time but thank you
and congressman connolly and buyer
they're both members of congress but uh
congressman conley got to the congress
with a real impediment
he worked for me for years before that
on my staff
and everything's gone downhill since you
left thank you
and uh i want to thank the speaker as
well and the senate majority uh
leader uh as well as uh thank all of you
working so hard for the people here in
northern virginia
four months after i took office we are
further along in this fight
than anyone thought possible let's
remember where we were 129 days ago
when i took office we were averaging 184
000 cases per day nationwide
here in virginia the governor pointed
out schools were closed
main street had gone quiet here in
cities all across america
virginia tech didn't play in a bowl game
this winter first time in
28 years and so many joys of life
large and small had been hauled it by a
long
dark winter and today you've gone from
184 cases per day nationwide
to fewer than 22 cases 22 000 cases
per day deaths have dropped by over 85
percent
tens of thousands of moms and dads
grandpas and grandmas brothers sisters
neighbors friends
are still with us today who would
otherwise have been lost
this has been true here in virginia
particularly
from 43 000 cases the week before i took
office
to fewer than 2 800 in the past week a
93 percent decline
we've been able to do it for three
reasons first
we plan and executed a vaccination
effort at a scale and speed
never before seen here or anywhere in
the world
here in virginia that meant 247 million
dollars in federal funding for
community vaccinations sites over 360
federally funded national guard members
supporting the state's
coven 19 response getting doses to
community health care centers
a thousand pharmacies all across
virginia
and creating a mass vaccination site in
norfolk
initially run by the federal emergency
management agency
and the united states navy in
partnership with virginia
second reason that we succeeded is
governors like governor north have been
instrumental partners
leaders in red states and blue states
working with businesses
faith leaders community groups to get it
done at a local level
and thirdly and most crucially the
american people
more than 165 million americans so far
have done their patriotic duty 165
million
and gotten at least one shot americans
of every party every race
creed have come together rolled up their
sleeves
literally and done their part
now 51 percent of american adults have
been fully vaccinated
75 percent of seniors fully
vaccinated leaving nobody behind black
white hispanic across the world
across the board they've been getting
their vaccinations
in virginia 55 as the governor said of
all adults are vaccinated
i believe that's the right number goat
and look at what that means
we aren't just saving lives we're
getting our lives back
stores and restaurants up and down main
street are
hanging open signs on their front doors
and here
the rock climbing gym we're greeted by
another and we're greeting one another
with smiles with our masks off
and i'm about to do this 60-foot wall
but
i tell you what i work out every morning
but i said i i have trouble holding
those grips that
and the young man said to me he said the
way to work your hands
he said get a kettlebell a light one and
just put it under your fingers and work
it that way
tonight i'm trying
but folks look in norfolk and
fredericksburg
fans are are heading back to the minor
league ballparks
pools and parks are opening up across
the state families are heading down to
spend memorial day weekend at virginia
beach and
all over the country we've gone from
pain
and stagnation of a long dark winter
to an economy on the growing masters has
nearly 40 years from deeming job
creation
in the months before i took office to
the fastest job creation
in the first three months of any
administration in american history and
rising witches rising wages
[Applause]
as more americans get vaccinated the
days grow brighter and brighter but let
me be clear
we're not done yet we have to reach
those who are not vaccinated and make it
as easy as possible for them to get
protected
i set an ambitious goal of getting 70
percent of adult americans
at least one shot by july the 4th today
just over a month to go
we're at 62 percent 10 states
have already reached the 70 percent
milestone
virginia 66 is moving closer every day
and continuing on all counting
on on just all the help and continuing
this process
is really i think you're going to get
the job done here in virginia pretty
quickly go
to 70 and keep sprinting through the
finish line
is what we're all about if we succeed we
can celebrate our independence from the
virus together on the fourth of july as
we celebrate our independence as a
nation
and the future is only going to get
brighter because there will be no doubt
what america can achieve
when we do it together i know when i ran
for office i said i wanted to do three
things
one of which was to unite the country
it's difficult
but this is the first real evidence that
we're able to do it the american people
are more ready to come together i
believe than the congress and the
elected officials are but we're getting
there
if you aren't vaccinated yet it's never
been easier
if convenience is the issue there are 80
000 locations visit vaccines.gov
or text your zip code to 438829
and you'll find the site's nearest
you'll pop up immediately and
on almost all cases you don't need an
appointment
if transportation is an issue i want to
thank lyft and uber
they've come forward and they've offered
free rides
to and from vaccination sites through
july 4th
so anybody who says they can't get there
called lift or uber
they're doing a patriotic thing they'll
come and pick you up
take you to the vaccination center get
you wait for you and take you back to
your home or wherever you
emerge from and you know it costs
is an issue don't let don't be concerned
the vaccine is 100 free and if time
is an issue there are 10 000 sites
offering vaccinations without an
appointment 1 000 pharmacies in virginia
alone
and the vast majority offer at no
appointment
with no appointment required we've made
extraordinary progress
every american should be proud of what
we've accomplished and we did it
together
but we still have five weeks left to hit
our goal
you know we and i know we can do it just
look what we've done so far
there's not a single thing and i've been
saying this a long time and i think
a lot of the press or smartest devil
think i'm being naive
there's nothing we cannot accomplish if
we do it together i really believe that
nothing nothing nothing we've ever set
our mind to as americans
that we've failed that we've done it
together and virginia
you know you're doing your part so you
know i remember always hear the uh
in the last administration i'd hear when
they talk about vaccines and
that uh we're gonna and we're gonna make
great progress you say there's light at
the end of the tunnel
i was reminded of my generation in the
60s
there was a very raunchy comedian who
said yeah there's light
we're talking about the vietnam war i
said yeah there's light at the end of
the tunnel
it's a freight train this time there's
sunlight at the end of the tunnel
there's real light there's real life and
gov i really mean this
not being political you've done one hell
of a job doc
you've done a hell of a job and it
matters it matters
so i thank you all god bless you
god protect our troops and
tell me why ain't in the school
all right
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
come on
thanks